and in Pennsylvania
hi Dan how are you yeah I'm doing fine
thanks Dave good so here's my situation
down hi I'm a school teacher I also have
a side business make about a hundred
grand a year
I took it advantage I have about twenty
thousand dollars left on my mortgage I
do also have a home equity line of
credit on the house just kind of there I
took advantage with the stock market as
a first-time investor when everything
crashed and convulsion ears on this one
but I went ahead and borrowed about
seventeen thousand and I invest as low
and slow in the market using we'll call
it America 2.0 stocks these are kind of
the future stocks portfolio is up about
22% my highest gain is two hundred and
four percent my lowest gain is a
negative 46 it's about 30 companies $500
a piece so its gain nicely this is all
buy and hold my question is as my
business generates more income and if I
have extra income
I'm loving the stock market and have a
lot of fun I feel part of these
companies should I use that to invest
more or should I try to tackle the
17,000 that I borrowed for the line of
credit to invest well I guess you can
probably not listen to us for very long
I wouldn't have done nor would I
continue to do anything you're doing so
I will tell you to do that I mean it's
not going to cause you to go bankrupt at
the level you're doing it but you're
under the illusion that you can continue
this because you happen to catch and
ride one wave and now you think you're a
pro surfer you're gonna get you're gonna
get your head taken off when this market
shifts a different direction and you
don't see it coming projecting the stock
market was going to go up from its low
the spring did not require rocket
scientist level of thinking most people
kind of knew that so you caught a wave
that everybody was catching and you know
you're under the illusion that you're
emotionally connected but these
companies who don't even know you exist
nor do they care if you exist
I wouldn't even say that out loud again
so now you do what you want to do dude
but no I would not borrow money to
invest and no I would not invest in
single stocks and you know there you're
obviously a math guy and you're having
fun with the math and I get that I'm
kind of nerdy I like the math stuff too
and it's kind of its kind of a monopoly
game for you
thank God it's 17,000 it's not you know
170,000 or 1.7 million at which point
you would have actually emotionally
absorbed the risk that you were taking
and realized that you're playing you
know you're playing Yahtzee here and
you're asking for it now you may you're
probably gonna get out of this alive I
mean it's pretty you probably will get
out of this and actually make money with
what you're doing but one time when we
were on a cruise can when we were 22
years old or 24 years all the very first
times I went on cruise my wife who is so
freaking stingy
we got change this is back on the cruise
when they would actually use money on
the cruise now they don't use money on
the cruise they use your room card or
whatever anyway she got changed and she
went by the sleaze little slot machines
and dropped a quarter and the slot
machine thought it was funny
well guess what oh no she hit it she won
so you know what the next thing you know
what we did for the rest of the cruise
we put hundreds of dollars more Frank
plus everything she made right back into
those machines yes because she hit once
and that's the danger yes tough to walk
away with the winnings once you once you
hit you think you know what you think
you got it figured out and all that all
the data says that 78% of the day
traders lose money the fact that you
have in puts you in the top twenty two
percent I'm not gonna do any kind of
investing game that I have to be in the
top twenty two percent perpetually to
keep from losing money much less make
money yeah so now I don't borrow money
which adds to the risk and I don't play
single stocks which adds to the risk so
sorry man if you want to do all that
certainly it's okay with you you you
know you're you're a grown-up but you
called us to ask our advice and that's
that's that's what we